BY, PAULA, WE APPRECIATE IT.
>>> SOMEONE WHO HE'S SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WORKING WITH DONALD
TRUMP, BARBARA RES IS A FORMER
TRUMP ORGANIZATION EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT, AN ATTORNEY,
ENGINEER, AND AUTHOR OF "TOWER
OF LIES: WHAT MY 18 YEARS OF
WORKING WITH DONALD TRUMP
REVEALS ABOUT HIM."
BARBARA, THE COMPANY HAS GOTTEN
USED TO A RINSE, WASH, AND
REPEAT CYCLE IN WHICH HE IS LET
OFF THE HOOK INCLUDING BY MANY
REPUBLICANS WHO SEE NO EVIL,
HEAR NO EVIL, AND EMBRACE
CONSPIRACIES AND ELECTION LIES
IN THE WAKE OF JANUARY 6, AS YOU
KNOW ALL TOO WELL.
BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT HOW
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION WORKS, DO
YOU THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP
HIMSELF IS IN LEGAL JEOPARDY
HERE?
WHAT DO YOU SEE HAPPENING THIS
WEEK?
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY HAVE
AND WHAT THEY'RE GOING AFTER.
I HEAR THEM TALK ABOUT GOING
AFTER THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
BUT THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION IS
NOT GENERAL MOTORS.
IT WAS JUST A KIND OF LOOSE
THING THAT WE CALLED OURSELVES.
I THINK IT WAS INCORPORATED, BUT
LATER, AFTER I STARTED THERE.
I'M SURE THAT EVERYTHING, EVERY
OPERATION THAT HE HAS, IS HELD
IN A HOLDING COMPANY OR AN LLC.
SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
ENTITIES OR WHERE THEY'RE GOING
WITH THIS.
AS FAR AS TRUMP WAS CONCERNED,
IF THEY WERE TO GET EVIDENCE
AGAINST TRUMP, IT WOULD BE TO
THE EXTENT THAT REALLY NOTHING
MAJOR HAS EVER HAPPENED, TO MY
KNOWLEDGE.
AND THIS IS CONFIRMED BY OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WORKED FOR HIM MUCH
LATER, THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT, NOTHING MAJOR.
SO HE IS IN WITH BOTH LEGS.
I THINK THAT IF THEY GET
SOMETHING, IT WILL BE TO GO
AFTER TRUMP.
WEISSELBERG, I'M SURPRISED HE'S
NOT TALKING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HE CAN'T GET A PARDON.
IT SORT OF EXPLAINS SOME OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE, BUT TRUMP HAS GO
ON HIM, I WOULD IMAGINE.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I CAN
THINK OF.
IF HE DOES CONSIDER, YOU KNOW,
REFUSING TO FLIP, AND, YOU KNOW,
THE EXPRESSION "FLIP" IMPLIES
GUILT, I MEAN, WHY WOULD TRUMP
SAY "HE WON'T FLIP"?
"FLIP" MEANS HE'S GOT SOMETHING.
WEISSELBERG COULD GO TO JAIL FOR
A VERY LONG TIME.
>> CNN TRIED TO GET HIM ON THE
AIR ABOUT THAT.
>> IS THERE ANY INFORMATION YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE US REGARDING
THE CASE?
>> NO COMMENT.
>> DO YOU CURRENTLY PAY TAXES ON
THE APARTMENT OR CAR THAT YOU
OWN?
>> NO COMMENT.
>> SOMETIMES THE QUESTIONS
AREN'T VERY NICE.
AS YOU KNOW, WEISSELBERG'S
COOPERATION COULD BE A TURNING
POINT IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
HOW VALUABLE WOULD WEISSELBERG
BE, DO YOU THINK, KNOWING WHAT
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION?
>> IN ITS PRESENT FORM,
WEISSELBERG IS PROBABLY THE MOST
INFORMED PERSON THERE, THE
PERSON THAT KNOWS THE MOST.
AS THEY SAY, WHERE THE BODIES
ARE BURIED.
I THINK ALLEN IS ESSENTIAL.
THEY DID INTERVIEW JEFF MACONEY,
THE COMPTROLLER, THE CONTROLLER
THEY CALL HIM.
HE PROBABLY HAD A LOT OF
INFORMATION.
HE MAY HAVE HAD INFORMATION ON
ALLEN AND TRUMP BOTH.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO SAY.
THEY PLAY IT CLOSE TO THE VEST.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE.
BUT ALLEN IS DEFINITELY THE KEY
GUY.
>> AND BARBARA, KNOWING WHAT YOU
KNOW ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AFTER
ALL OF THESE YEARS, DO YOU THINK
HE BELONGS IN JAIL?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT ONLY WHAT
I KNEW OF HIS PERSONALITY AND
THE WAY HE OPERATES, BUT WHAT
I'VE OBSERVED OVER 20 YEARS,
REALLY THE LAST FIVE OR SIX,
CERTAINLY.
I MEAN, THAT'S AN OPINION OF A
CITIZEN, NOT EVEN SOMEBODY THAT
KNOWS TRUMP.
BUT I DO KNOW HIM, AND I KNOW
THAT HE'S VERY DELIBERATE, VERY
MEASURED, AND VERY VENGEFUL.
AND HE DOESN'T FOLLOW THE RULES.
HE NEVER DID FOLLOW THE RULES.
SO DOES HE DESERVE TO GO TO
JAIL?
I IMAGINE HE DOES.
>> ARE YOU SURPRISED BY WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED AFTER
THAT?
>> I WAS HORRIFIED BY IT.
I DIDN'T EXPECT ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
WHAT HAPPENED AFTERWARDS IS JUST
A DISGRACE.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE DISGRACE.
AND NOW, IN RETROSPECT, IT LOOKS
LIKE TRUMP AND OTHER REPUBLICANS
MAY VERY W